الجمهوري روندي سانتوس الذي فاز بمصر
الحاكم بعد التغلب على الديمقراطيه تشارلي
كريست في فلوريدا
[تصفيق]
وفي ولايه فلوريدا كان يوحي بانها ارض
الميعاد
ونحن كنا قد اعتنقنا الحريه والنظام
والقانون وقمنا بحمايه حقوق الابواين
واحترمنا دافعين ضرائب ورفضنا
العايديولوجيات غير المقبوله
بالعمل من خلال محاربه العالم من اجل طرح
تشريعات مناسبه ولن نقوم بالانصياع الى
الغوغاء التي نشهدها في ولايه فلوريدا
الناس جاءوا الى هنا لان سياستنا قد افلحت
فل فالقياده هي مساله مهمه مهمه ونرفض
استخدام هذه
العمليات التصويت هذه زعماء لا يجب عليهم
ان يتحلوا بالقياده وان يرسم الرؤيا وان
نحن قمنا بتنفيذ هذه الرؤيه وقدمنا نتائج
تاريخيه والناس في هذه الولايه قد تجاوبوا
بصوره همم تحمل في طياتها
سجلنا بلادنا تخوم وبتارجح بسبب الفشل
القياده في واشنطن فلوريدا تسير في
الاتجاه الصحيح اعتقد ان بقاء التجربه
الامريكيه تتطلب واعاده احياء المبادئ
الامريكيه الحقيقيه
بان هذا يمكن فعله فنحنه قادرون
على طرح بادره امل والايام المثاليه ما
تزالوا بانتظارنا انا فخور بانجازه
بانجازاتنا وانا لا اشعر بالفخر بدعمكم
واتطلعه الى الطريق المستقبلي وقد حطوا
هذه المعركه وقد انهيت السباق وفي السوق
بالمراتب الاولى
[تصفيق]
نحن همم
وقمنا منذ اربع سنوات
بفعلي كل ما يجب فعله وانا مستعد للحرب
الان شكرا جزيلا فل يبارك لكم شكرا على
نصركم الكبير
[تصفيق]